before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
awkward pun title
unnecessary political commentary
oversimplified basic premise
must be arachnids in the uk
[Music]
oh boy i was not looking forward to
revisiting this this was like there were
a number of things that i didn't really
care for about
series 11 but i really this was the only
episode i deeply actively hated even
first time i saw it
and i was not looking forward to coming
back to it
having now done so
i'm not gonna say it's not as bad as i
remember it being what i'll say is once
you're prepped for what it is
it's
slightly more tolerable i found it less
infuriating than i did the first time
because part of what really infuriated
me the first time was while i didn't
think doctor who in this particular
series was really knocking out a park
with every episode or really hadn't
blown me away with any of them i still
saw a lot of potential in the
presentation the characters the way
things were happening and then this
comes out of nowhere with this
deeply lazy basic sci-fi premise the
kind of thing that's been around since
the earliest days of science fiction
film and this bungled political
commentary and i just
i wasn't prepared i wasn't prepared for
the ways in which this was bad
because the ones up to this point even
when i hadn't totally clicked with them
i got what they were doing i could get
behind the idea of it at least i largely
was having execution issues
this i'm like what what what are you
doing why would you even do this
and now that i already know it's here
and it's not blindsiding me with its
mere existence
there's some stuff that works and the
stuff that doesn't work isn't
as painful
because it's not unexpected i think that
was the thing this was bad in ways i had
not anticipated
doctor who being bad and it really
blindsided me on first viewing second
viewing
it's more tolerable
it's not really any better
there are a couple of bits here and
there that kind of work
but
let's get into it starting right at the
front end we've got a couple of things
that i actually like and then they kind
of come unraveled later
i like
that when
nadja shows up at the hotel a little
ahead of when she's supposed to and runs
into jack robinson he just fires her but
what i like about that is the build up
to that moment
and his delivery of that line he
delivered you're fired the way you would
expect a more standard uh
doctor who or any kind of villain to say
uh kill her
and i like that first of all because it
kind of
gives the indication of where they're
going in terms of depicting this as a
businessman that like yeah he's
absolutely the villain and we're gonna
portray him in the way we portray any
villain even if his words are you're
fired instead of kill her
but in addition to that it makes him
kind of pathetic like any decent villain
would have killed her you're just gonna
fire her that's the best you've got you
pitiful tiny little man
the problem is that kind of gets undone
once the reveal happens that this is in
fact
yaz's
mother and again i i'm i'm feeling the
i'm seeing the hands of the author and
i'm feeling the sense of reverse
engineering i would bet you money
that if nadja was not yaz's mother
she would have been killed and the only
reason they didn't and thus resulted in
a moment i liked is because they weren't
going to kill yaz mom
i don't know if that's actually true but
it's how it feels
they got a moment that i thought really
worked and then i realized oh you didn't
do that on purpose you stumbled into it
because you working backwards you knew
you couldn't kill her
ah
again i can't prove that's the case but
it's what it feels like
and that in and of itself is a problem
especially given that this continues to
feed into what i brought up previously
about needless cruelty
so in this case we have frankie which is
jack's niece in law i guess again
same pattern establish one
theoretically relatable thing about this
person
and then kill them the only difference
between frankie and every other dang
time the show is doing this is that she
doesn't die in the same scene she dies
in the second scene she appears in now
at this point given that i am now seeing
this pattern uh and you know with like
the grandfather in the woman who fell to
earth i don't think this is an issue of
definitely not deliberate
bury your gays it is however stumbling
into that trope just by being so
freaking callous there is no point in
frankie there's actually there's almost
no point frankie existing as a character
at all but there's definitely no point
in killing her this way we have two
deaths that we needed to establish the
threat we have the body that gets found
in the apartment which establishes the
initial issue of these spiders are
attacking and can kill people and then
the death of kevin which is jack's
bodyguard that establishes that they are
dangerous enough to take down someone
who is armed and trained those are all
necessary things to establish those two
deaths serve a purpose frankie's serves
none
none whatsoever in theory uh it's where
she goes and ultimately ends up getting
killed is uh it establishes like this
secret basement with all the warning
signs on it but like they could have
just come up to that it would have
worked fine not having seen it
previously
and like only the audience has seen it
previously so like
what difference does it make if we saw
it earlier or just saw it for the first
time later on when the actual characters
who matter showed up to see it
again
needless death cruel
death
don't like it coming back to some of the
stuff that worked a bit better um
because we're gonna deal with some stuff
that
really doesn't in a minute but some of
the stuff that did actually kind of work
and i hadn't really remembered the
interactions with the doctor and the
companions in terms of like her not
wanting to
leave and be on her own and them
ultimately deciding to go with her
there's a couple of hiccups in there
like i kind of wish that at the front
end when um they're initially saying
their goodbyes that the doctor was a
little less
incredibly on the nose and insanely
readable as just being like
i really wish you'd say like it's so
super obvious i kind of wish she had
just been a little bit quiet because
then it could have been just yaz when
she offered her to come uh to tea and
the doctor was like yes please it could
have been yaz reading her in a way the
other characters weren't and seeing
through her trying to be you know oh no
i'm fine but it read so clearly obvious
that she wasn't fine that it doesn't
come across as the as being insightful
it does come across as yaz being kind
and caring and that's not nothing but
you could have established more about
the character than you did just because
the way that that moment is played that
said jazz plays it pretty well and also
say this
while i'm still not much of a shipper uh
and i've got my video out there on the
whole thasman thing that you know check
that video out there
but
especially based off this episode i
definitely get why it happened because
you actually have nadja uh he has his
mother specifically saying are you two
seeing each other so it gets suggested
in the show and there are some moments
between them that are some looks that
okay
coming back to it now because like again
since i don't like
shipping in general and i really don't
like the doctor in a romantic
relationship especially especially with
a companion i kind of deliberately put
blinders on i choose to not see that but
knowing that it eventually happens and
coming back and looking at this now i'm
like okay yeah like you could definitely
see that moment and be like there's
starting to be
feelings there uh at the very least on
yaz's part so
in hindsight uh that stuff is starting
to build towards that again like as i
said in my video on that not
intentionally yet at this point but like
i get where it came from it didn't come
out of nowhere and i like that at the
end when the companions do finally
choose to go with her that like
everybody
has a reason that they're doing this i
it to my memory like they just kind of
went with her that isn't really true
though and what's interesting is that
all of the companions are kind of
running away from something some more
deliberately and um obviously than
others yaz is kind of escaping her
family something we'll learn later she's
done before she's run away before
so that
that is sort of a laying in of that
aspect of her character graham just flat
out says i'm not prepared to process
grace being gone on my own and then ryan
is a is a bit more like well i just
don't want to work in that warehouse but
given the stuff that is brought up
earlier in this very episode about his
dad you can tell like he's kind of
avoiding some pain too
so they do lay out the reasons for these
companions to go with the doctor i don't
really think they laid out much of a
reason for the doctor to gravitate
towards them other than they were just
the first people she had any adventures
with but
that's not no reason
it is a reason i suppose theoretically
had they been anybody else something
similar likely would have happened at
least on her part and wanting them to
stick around
just because previous doctors have had
like very deliberate ooh you're
intriguing and i want to find out more
about you sort of things with a lot of
their companions doesn't mean that is
the only way to do it this did a little
different and honestly looking back on
it it's fine i kind of both
like but feel weird about the moment
where the doctor is talking to i forget
her name but the the woman who was
studying the spiders who's trying to get
uh to see her her colleague in a room
and the doctor basically says like like
i could sort the lock if you're really
worried about your friend part of me is
like i kind of like that she's waiting
for permission
instead of just barging in but then
another part of me is like that really
feels like a cop moment
you know like when they're outside a
door like we don't really have a reason
to go in there
unless uh somebody is fearful for the
safety of anybody in there you are okay
like
accidental i suspect but there's
something odd about a moment with the
doctor feeling to me like an equivalent
to something that happens with cops a
lot
to me the doctor shouldn't feel like a
cop so like it i kind of like it as a
moment but it also makes me feel weird
like i'm i'm in an ambivalent place
about that but it stood out to me this
time but okay let's
let's get to what really doesn't work
here which is two main things one is
jack robinson as a character who is not
as terrible as i remember him but
there's specific aspect of his character
that like absolutely does not work and
then the
incredibly confused morals and ethics of
this episode let's start with robinson
so in terms of him being a businessman
and a lousy businessman you know a lousy
human being doing shady business dodging
responsibility for it i mean that works
and like it's very obvious that he is
meant to evoke trump between one of the
first things he says being you're fired
the whole thing with hotels him uh you
know dodging responsibilities being like
this is not my fault and all like all
these things they build up to a
trump-esque character and honestly as
much as it is kind of a little on the
nose ham-fisted political commentary uh
it was fine
for what it was i kind of still wish it
wasn't there but it was fine for what it
was because he definitely had enough
signifiers to make you think of trump
but also he was not doing a trump
impression and had a very different uh
sort of personality and line delivery
than trump so that
i'm not going to say that gave a
distance but that made him feel like a
character not a caricature
until they bring up the idea that he has
political aspirations which after they
do that they immediately establish that
trump does exist and is in the white
house and so all of this makes
no sense
at all
because you're saying your trump analog
exists in the same world where trump
also exists like
then why are you using an analog
it makes the whole idea of even adding
this element confusing it makes his
character and the idea and like his very
notions of his political ambitions
bizarre and strange and make no sense
because like he's got a moment he has
times where he says specific things that
trump was well noted for saying things
like fire and fury and then later saying
like this is what people need this is
what's going to get me in the white
house like dude if trump is real and his
president that's already what's going to
be in the white house the reason trump
got in was the sense of him being
disruptive to the normal flow of
business he was not the norm but if he's
in the off the oval office already then
he is now the norm what is it that you
think you're gonna offer to voters that
he already isn't like yes robinson is
pig-headed enough to think he's still
something different to trump but like it
makes the whole political element like
weird and confused and
i'm not sure toothless is the right word
but it just takes the wind out of the
sails because it's like wait you have
somebody that is a copy of somebody in
real life but also that person in real
life also exists in your fiction like
this this is this is muddled this is
bizarre and like i know they had kind of
already established that trump was a
thing because there was a reference to
the orange president uh by bill back in
series 10 but like that's like you
didn't have to draw this kind of
attention to it it makes it fall flat
something that already was only kind of
working in the first place
but then
then we've got the insanely
bizarre
ethics going on
because the doctor gets super uppity
about
jack
shooting the spiders
except
his initial stated intention to do so
and then his later act of doing so
comes after
the doctor and and companions plan is
all ready to kill the spiders
we shut them in and isolate them you're
going to let spiders use my panic room
they deserve a humane natural death
shooting's quicker
humanely quote unquote but like you're
already planning to kill them
and you're all so but you're getting on
a moral high horse
over the way
this guy wants to kill them and i'm not
saying that like there's no
moral difference between humanely
putting down an animal and just shooting
it i'm not saying they are equivocal but
as a moral position for the doctor to
get as uppity as she does that is
a bizarre bit of hair splitting because
actually at no point
is she trying to figure out how to keep
these things alive and safe and
relocate them or i don't know something
that's never in the cards the plan is
always to kill them
and you just have a problem with the
fact that he wants to do it with a gun
and there might be way there might be
some way
to make that not freaking bizarre and
strange
but
they don't do it it's like the show is
glommed onto the idea the doctor doesn't
use guns and hasn't thought about why
the doctor doesn't use guns the doctor
isn't really okay most of the time
with things dying if they don't have to
and the fact that no other alternatives
are even entertained
is just ah
and like with the giant spider
it's already dying it's suffocating then
he comes in and shoots it and he calls
it a uh mercy killing now granted that
wasn't on his mind when he shot it at
the first place he just shot it because
he wanted to shoot and feel like a big
man but like he's not wrong
slow death by suffocation that's not
exactly a peaceful and humane way to die
so what
it's the fact that the doctor gets on
this moral high ground over it
on what basis what moral high horse do
you think you're sitting on
and it's not even necessarily bad ethics
like i've harped on doctor who for bad
morals before like i when i go off on
something like the idiot's lantern which
i think has horrific
moral implications with its ending
that's not the case here this isn't like
these are bad morals like these are just
confusing
these just don't make sense it's a
different problem and it's one i'm more
baffled by than infuriated by at this
particular point and coming back to
robinson real quick i feel like i can
use him and interactions with him as a
couple more examples of things just
being written really on the nose because
there are a number of exchanges with him
where again if you were to bullet point
the scene for me here's what will get
set yell at like as an outline like as a
script outline here's the scene that's
going to happen here are the points that
are going to be said to robinson i would
look then go that's a solid scene so
like when they're in the mine and if you
diagram out the scene
they come in they realize what's going
on the cause of it robinson and or his
companies is behind most of it and he is
dodging responsibility for it and they
call him out on that on paper totally
works but the fact that a character
literally just says to his face and
you're just avoiding responsibility like
you just you just had someone say what
the intention of the scene was you
didn't turn it into dialogue you didn't
turn it into an action you just took the
bullet point of what the scene is
supposed to accomplish and just made it
dialogue
and that is kind of happening repeatedly
especially when chibnall himself is the
one writing the scripts the sense of
what ideas are being communicated by
these lines are fine but they are just
being said flat out there's no
like here's the line and here's the
subtext it's just like he the subtext is
just the text
and that
that's just
bad
writing i'm sorry it just is
and like one other tiny thing that just
stuck out to me
i kind of hate that robinson mentions
earlier on that there that he has a
panic room
and then later the doctor's like show me
your panic room i kind of wish like he
hadn't brought it up earlier but she
just realizes he's the kind of jackass
who would have a panic room that nobody
else knows about and she just says show
me your panic room knowing that he has
it
again it feels like that reverse
engineering oh we should establish why
the doctor knows this why can't she just
know why can't she just get a read on
this guy and figure out what kind of
[ __ ] he is and call him on it
again it's the hand of the authors the
reverse engineering thing
this episode is not good
not quite as infuriating as the first
time i saw it but boy it ain't good
or acting's in the uk what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is how i'm able to
pay the bills like share and subscribe
also help me out if you are able to do
any of that don't worry too much about
it
because what i really want you to know
is that you're beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin lutfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idolm tracy scrabbat
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourlay and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]